yeah dude this uh
this strike came up Isn't it nice to not
have to worry about that yeah I feel for
them I hope they get the I think they'll
I think it'll come around the SAG after
strike yeah right here negotiations
cratered over AI streaming Revenue
sharing
pay hikes and more can you get to that
article just a little bit that's tough I
did like what Fran Drescher said I
thought it was pretty cool to see her
vid the no The Nanny yeah I used to have
a crush on her oh who didn't dude
it's a weird choice that she's the head
of this how did it become her well the
funny thing was a lot of people didn't
know right yeah because like I've always
you get the things in the mailboxes like
vote for this person you know and I
always try to vote for like
the crit you know I vote for like the
wildest person to put in there because
sometimes they're on there right I know
it's like Wendy Williams yeah Kanye yeah
yeah or Robert FK Jr yeah yeah let's put
somebody in there yeah it was really
gonna make something happen yeah let's
shake it up
oh here we go frankly
how far apart we are on so many things
how they plead poverty that they're
losing money left and right when giving
hundreds of millions of dollars to their
CEOs
it is disgusting shame on them
they stand on the wrong side of history
at this very moment
we stand in solidarity
in unprecedented Unity
our Union and our sister unions and the
unions around the world
are standing by us
as well as other labor unions that's
good
that's interesting huh I mean I feel
like she really kind of I feel like she
you definitely feel what she's saying
yeah yeah they got millions and they
can't give the writer Some I know
the residuals thing is a bummer
well I think in a lot of it goes back to
just the history of people not getting
residuals you know it's like all those
years of people on shows and you hear
that they don't have they didn't make
any money from you know like you hear
that a lot about the cast from like
Saved by the Bell and stuff like that
like they were on those hit shows right
and they didn't that it just wasn't part
of their deals I know so I think a lot
of you have that old energy that's built
up so she went through all that right
um the problem is on Twitter you have so
many people that come out against her
and are like oh here's a millionaire you
know trying to say what uh what the
regular person wants and it's like but
still somebody has to
um
somebody has to speak up you know yeah
yeah and I think they'll be fine but
that sucks should be a writer and just
like ah We're Not Gonna We're not gonna
pay you well also because a lot of the
writers they work on spec you know they
do a project first and bring It Forward
oh yeah so I think when you partner in
the fact they're doing all of that work
yeah and then which some of those things
never lead to anywhere true how many
friends do we have that have probably
written five scripts I've written three
scripts I've written a million packets
SNL whatever TV show yeah and they just
steal your jokes yes hey here's my jokes
like you never hear back I know you
actually have to sign a thing when you
turn in a packet that says hey this is
not yours anymore you send it to us and
you're like that's that's my best sketch
I need that let me shoot it if you're
not gonna hire me it's on it really is
man it's such a um
it's a it's a sick business and there's
never any accountability you don't know
once you send that packet off what
happens yeah and then now you have all
these yeah you have a lot of actors and
I guess they're
um they're worried about AI which makes
sense you know they're worried about all
of that ai's getting good man I uh
people send me jokes that they put an AI
in my voice and I'm like that's pretty
good that's better than anything I ever
had
also I'm a robotic guy who tells jokes
wow now ai's taking my it's a good
point huh yeah it's scary but I think
maybe that's also one of the reasons why
people want to come see something that's
real hope you enjoyed that video and you
can watch another and you can watch this
one you can watch this one different
options different choices some guy just
brings you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one